サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
えーと 今日の説法の法政いわゆる皆様にブッダの真理を聞いてくださいと
このお布施くださったのは
まあこのホールのね 金額をね
費用をね お布施していただきましたのは米沢様でございます
で あの お布施の中であの法政っていうのは一番重要なお布施になります
皆様はまあ米沢様は金額をお布施したんだけど
その金額は何に使うのかと
すべての人々に悪行為をやめて善に達して
真理の道を歩むために必要な力を与えたんですね
ですから 皆様方も説法を聞くと
またさらなる米沢さんへの功徳になります
それだけではなくて またいろいろボランティアの方々がたくさん早くから来て準備したり
いろいろボランティアで活動なさったことも
それはすべて法政したことになります
功徳のあまり上下関係はないんですけど
自分の気持ち次第で功徳が強烈な功徳になったり
まあそれほどその気持ちがなくて逃げられないから協力すると
それぐらいの功徳になったりはします
とにかく米沢米沢いずる様に幸福がありますように
三宝に守られますように
毎日心が清らかになりますように
すべての煩悩がなくなりますように
涅槃に達に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
皆様で三回サードサーグ
サーグ サーグ はい それから皆様方にもこれから説法を聞きますので
大変な功徳になります
で 瞑想することとだいたい似ているエネルギーになります
俗世間のくだらない話ではないんですね
ブッダの話は まあそれに私がいっぱいくだらない話を入れますけど
純粋にブッダの話っていうのは必ず心清らかになる
大変な功徳になる話なので
皆様方にもこの説法の功徳でブッダの真理を聞くことで幸福でありますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
あらゆる病気やら災いやら
ないこと 不幸なことから
ブッダの力によって 真理の力によってなくなります
なくなりますように 心が清らかになりますように
完全たる幸福である涅槃に達することができますようにと皆様方も誓願してください
はい  3回 サーグ サーグ
サーグ はい では今日のお話に入ります
あの このように枝多き 3つのものということになりますけど
話の内容は 5つのものになりますけどね
お釈迦様のレアキャラ論
まあレアといえばね あの
だいたい誰だってありがたくは思うんですね
それはそんなに大げさな問題ではないんです
あまりにレアなものだったら
博物館とかね そういうところで
美術館などなどで置いとかなくちゃいけないしね
考えてみれば だからこそ価値があるかないかよくわからないんですね
例えばフランスにあるモナリザという絵をね
誰かが盗んだからって売れないでしょ
売れないではなく だけじゃなくて
持っただけで大変なことになっちゃいますからね
だからまあ価値があるかよくわからないね
例えば日本のね 博物館やら美術館などにも
かなりの古いすごい高価なものは展示してありますね
じゃあ自分がそれをガラスケース破って持っていったからといって
結局一円の価値もなくなっちゃうんですね
ただ 自分が犯罪者になったことになるだけで
はい だからそういうことで面白いですよ
このレアっていうことはね
だからいくらか価値があって売買できるのは
本当はそれほどレアじゃないものなんです
本当にレアだったらもう一般人の手に入らないし
どこかで共有財産としてみんなのものとして置いておかなくちゃいけないんですね
だからびっくりするほどのレアなね
もう価値のある値札 値札つければ
ものすごい天文学的な数値がつくられる
仏像とかね ダラダラと日本のあの大きな博物館にありますよ
もう だから一つ自分が持っていたからといって
それはもうゼロ価値になっちゃうんです
その時点で でも私たちはいろいろレアなものを持っていますね
時々車の場合もスペシャルエディションとかいろいろありますね
そういうものはありがたがりますけど
そういうものは値段があるんだけど
よくよく見るとそれほどレアじゃないんですね
ある車の特別バージョンで
例えば 10万台作ると
それから作りませんと
やっぱり10万人それ買っちゃいますからね
それからそれは他の人に売ったりすることもできるしね
そういうところちょっと面白いんですね
本当に我々はレアだとありがたがるものっていうのは
本当にそれはレアだったら大変なことになる
それほどレアじゃないんですね
結局は それで自分が世界で一個しかないものを持っている
何の価値もなくなるんです
でしょ？だって何かにも比較することも
何することもできない
例えば 500g ぐらいの重さの宝石があると
まあありますからね そんな大したことないんだけど
まあダイヤがあると で
まあそれたった一つ一つしかなければ
ダイヤだったら他のダイヤと比較するんだから価値があるんだけどね
まあ例えば自分の子供が初めて書いた落書きでね
それで一個しかないでしょ
子供はさっさと成長するんだからね
まあ何枚か描いてくれと言ったってもできませんだからね
レアでしょ でも何の価値もないね
まあ時々ね 若い人々はね
まあ恋している時は この相手から初めてもらったプレゼントだと
例えばボールペン 女の人からもらっちゃって
あとはそれはもうすごい大事にするという
それレアですね 結局は
でも何の価値もないね
ある有名な人 あれがいたんですけど
このすごい有名で 知識人でね
で もう自分が手にはまってる時計はミッキーマウスの時計なんです
立派な知識人で 教授で
もうかなり本も出している人なんですけど
大きな講演なんかに立っても
みんなにバレちゃいますね
あのミッキーマウスの時計を持ってるんだから
なんだこれって変でしょと
そしたら彼の説明は 自分のお父さんが最初に初めて買ってくれたんだと
自分が小さい時 だから今はもう立派な大人で
大教授で 世界的な名前
ちょっと遠慮しますけど
あの世界的に知られている人で
大金持ちで もしかするとお父様がいるかいないかはわかりませんだけど
そんなすごい人が まあちっちゃな子供たちが見るミッキーマウスの古い時計
まだ古いんですよ 他の人にとっては
なんだこりゃ ゴミを捨てなさいという立場でしょ
でも本人はあの時計は決して外したくはないんです
自分が小学校の時ね あるいは 1年生の時
あるいは学校に行く前にね
お父さんがプレゼントだよと思って買ってあげたでしょうね
ちっちゃい時 そういうのは英語でエモーショナルバリューと言いますけど
センチメンタルバリューとも言いますよね
本人にしか価値がないね
でも あの今私が例に出したミッキーマウスの時計も
あれ一個しかないんです
世界に だからで どこかで売れますかね
あれは どこかにオークションに出しちゃって
誰も買いませんね だから悪い
もう頭にイカれてる この有名なタレントさんとか
なんだかんだああいう人々が使ったものを出したらね
かなりオークションですごい高い値札が付きますけどね
あの価値はどこから出てくる？誰かさんがね
もう舞台でこの衣装を着て
なんだか歌歌ったとかね
あるいはこの昔あったね
昔のロックのあれ 何でしたっけ？プレスリー
エルヴィス・プレスリー
で 彼の服やらもう汗だらだらだらと脱ぎ捨て
そのまま保管して奥谷で売ったりはする
そんな価値があるのか
レアものなんですけどね
そのレアの価値がどうやって現れるかと
人間のアホらしさなんですね
結局は だから何やとなんかガチャガチャガチャ歌だけで
歌っただけで それぐらい価値があるのかと
その時着ていた服にはとかね
そういうことで 誰かにサインしたものとかね
なんだらとかかんだら
有名人のサインの入れたなんたらかんたらとかね
言ったりとかね 本人の主観的な感情的なものでしょうね
実際 客観的に価格的な価値がないんですね
で まあそう言ったら まあ例えばダイヤとかね
特別大きいダイヤとかね
大きい宝石とかね とてもものすごくレア
自然界にもないんですね
たまに見つけたら これは本当のレアもので
すごい値札が入りますね
その時はエモーショナルバリューはないんですね
感情的な意味じゃなくて
客観的に見ると価値があると
10カラットのダイヤはこれぐらいになるんだから
こちらはもうもう1500カラットあるんだよとか
それで計算して価値付けるんだけど 1500
カラットぐらいあるの
石をね 決して磨いてカットしてすごいものにするっていうことは
また別に考えなくちゃいけない
できる場合はできない場合もあるんだからね
で その場合は一般人がすごい高いものだなと思うだけで
欲しいとは思わないね
それまた頭いかれてるバカたちがオークションでお金出して買う
買って誰も入らない家で置いておく
あの皆様に関係あるあの人
あのビルゲイツさんもね
いろんな絵画とかあれやとか買いまくっちゃって
どこかに置いておくんだけど
誰も見に行かないね  世の中のレアものっていうのはそんなもんなんですね
結局はくだらないんですよ
で 今日はいきなり今日テーマに入って説明します
世の中のレアなものについては喋る元気は今日ありません
そこで派手にスライド作る目的でもいたんだけど
まあ事故っちゃって指が動かなくなっちゃって
短いスライドにしたんです
これアンガッティ界のこの 5番目のセクションのね
あの  15の5番目の また 5番目のセクションで 3番目の経典なんですね
これサーサーラナンダドスッタというんですね
サーサーランダドサーランダド
リッチョ王族が考えた得難いもの
5つあったんですね このリッチョっていうのは
大体インドの北の方に入るウェスタリー国なんですけど
菩提樹あるところとか
そういうところからかなり北の方に行かないとね
で 特別な国なんですね
なんか注釈書ではなんでリッチョイチョイっていうのは皮膚なんですね
だからあまりにも皮膚が透明であると
その人々は まあ透明な皮膚だったらもう当然気持ち悪いんですけど
透明で中身見えちゃうとね
これはいい加減でではなくて
ものすごく皮膚の色が美しくなったでしょうとは思いますね
なんか何も汚れが入ってないような
まあその場合は言葉ではなんか透明な人間みたいなという風に言うしかない
あなたの皮膚はなんか透明ですねとかね
まあそこまで美しい皮膚の人々は今世間ではいませんし
まあ当時ではね まああり得ることなんだって
全て自然のものの中で
何の放射線もないしね
宇宙から来る宇宙線も地球に来ないしね
すごい自然の中でね 生きていたんだから
まああり得ることで 今は無理ですからね
それでこの王族の人々は
この国が王制 王制ではないんですね
いわゆる議会制度で 議会制度ですけど
だから現代的に選挙区選挙もないんですよ
ちょっとわからないね
あの議会制度の政府は
選挙はないんですけど
議員さんはいる この議員さんにみんなにリッチョウィ王と言うんですね
王というよりはプリンスと言うんですね
クマーララジクマーラ王子
だから議員さんたちはみんな王子さんたちでボスがいないんですね
議会制度って だからお釈迦様はあえて
あの議長認定することはもう避けるようにとアドバイスしていたみたいですね
だからインド文化では年上の人を尊敬する
道徳的にすごい信頼できる人を尊敬する
そうするとまとめ役はその人がやるんであって
だからといって権力を持っている
権限を持っている議長というわけではないんですね
だからある程度で格好いい政治システムなんですね
しかし 選挙がないとどうするのかいと
あれは世襲制度でしょうね
おそらく 王子がおじいさんになったところで
息子がお父さんの代わりに議会に行くということになるなったのではないかと思いますね
最近私はこの民主主義
デモクラシーということは
世の中でどこにもデモクラシーはないんだけど
ウィンストンチャーチルが言ったように
世の中にある一番最悪の政治システムはデモクラシーであると
他の政治システムは置いておいて考えればとかね
なんとか英語で言ったフレーズですけど
いわゆる他の政治システムは極端に最悪ですけど
その中 民主主義にしても最悪だと
なぜかって 民主主義で適任が選べないんですね
仕事に適したふさわしい人を選ぶことはできないんです
だってみんな投票するんだからね
みんな自分の気持ちで投票するんですね
だから気持ちってバカバカらしくて
もうあまり当てにならないでしょう
フィーリング だから一つの国が国民のフィーリングであなたやってくださいと気持ちで人を選んで最悪でしょうに
ただ気に入った それだけ
だから民主主義といってもろくな政治システムじゃないなと
だから だからお釈迦様から見れば
立憲共和国がいくらかマシなんですね
だって父親から育ててもらって
議員になるために教育を受けているんですね
わがままいい加減 好き勝手なことをしてはいけない
責任あるんだから あの家で生まれたんだから
そこで適齢になった年齢になったら
自分が1年前で議会に行って参加する
そうなってくると 人の気持ちで選ばれたわけじゃないんですね
どちらにしても 世の中の政治システムというのはまともなものは作れないということだけ確かなんですね
ずっと人類が政府のアホらしさで苦しまなくちゃいけないんですね
基本的に政府をやっている人々はかなり非道徳的で
わがままで 国民の財産はガチャガチャ無駄に使っているということになるんですね
最近ね トランプさんの性格も知ってるでしょうね
あんな人にアメリカは任せているんだからね
はい 無駄話はそこら辺にして次に行きましょう
このリッチ王族は このサラウンドでチェーティアというところで
このチェーティアっていうのは
このみんな集まっていろいろお祈りしたりするような
なんとなく神社みたいな
伊勢神宮みたいな かなり大きな場所なんですね
だから伊勢神宮に行って楽しく生活するために
別に神様を信じる必要もないでしょうに
神様は信じなくても かなり美しいところでね
川が流れていて とってもきれいな水が流れていて
もう自然の森があるわ
もう抜群でしょ だから本殿があるところの方に全く行かなくても
森で結構楽しく生活できる
それで気持ちも良くなる
このチェーディアっていうのは
そういう風な感じで みんな集まって修行したり
祈り祈ったりというところでもありながら
一般的な 何といいますか
オープン公園みたいな感じで
新宿御苑みたいな感じで
まあまあ行って見学したければはいどうぞっていう感じになる
日比谷公園とかあるでしょうね
代々木公園とかね  駒沢公園もあるしね
まあ行って人々はのんびりする場所で
そちらにあの 今例に出した公園みたいな
この全部設備できているわけじゃないんです
もう古いもの 自然なものですから
そこでこのリッチ王族がそこで
集まって まあおそらくこの若い年齢のグループのように気がしますけどね
世に得難いものは何なのかと話していたんですね
そこでまた見張りを置いておったんですね
だから リッチョイ君とお釈迦様の関係っていうのはものすごい密接な関係だから
まあそこら辺 お釈迦様があの修行でヴェーサーリ国を通るところになっているんですね
そこで見張りを置いておいて
お釈迦様が来るならば
遠くから来て直ちに報告してくださいと言って
そこ間でこの連中はガチャガチャガチャガチャとくだらない話をしているんです
おそらくお釈迦様も待っていたんですね
お釈迦様もその日はサーランダダというチェーティア
その場所に滞在する予定なんですね
だから先に王子たちがいて待っているんです
だからお釈迦様に失礼だから
いろいろ見張りを入れてあって
遠くからお坊さん お釈迦様とグループが来るならば
さっさと走ってきて報告しなさい
それでこちらでちゃんと大人しく常儀作法よくいることはできるんですね
このグループはかなり若者やと思いますね
この風に考えてみると
テーマは この世で得難いものとは何ですか？ということですね
だからもしかするとお釈迦様もすごい珍しい
ありえない方だから そこから頭が動かしたでしょうね
そうやって珍しいってものって何でしょうかねとかね
彼ら得難いものは五宝だと結論に達したのです
パンチャラタナ 宝物法という宝物というひらがなの意味でよろしい
宝物 宝物は必ず宝にならなくていいでしょうにね
宝石の意味ですけど  1番目ハッティラタナッスパートバハヲドゥルルベローカスミン
象法ですね これなかなかいないんだと
珍しいやと だからゾウはいくらでもいる
ゾウという動物ですからね
でもこの 象の中でもいるんですよ
この宝物になるゾウさんが
スリランカでも一頭いるんですよ
あまりにも人格があって
どこへ行ってもしっかりと
あの なんていうの大統領がどこかに行くような感じで
前と後ろ警察が行くんです
警察がない場合は軍人でも行ってしっかりと象を守ってあげているんです
だからあの ゾウさんがいると
だからどこへ行ったって
なんか偉い態度で行くんですよ
あの子は決して車に乗りたくないんです
歩いて行くんです 偉い態度なんです
だから今 スリランカではいろんなお寺にゾウを運んだりしてますから
お祭りにね 全部大きいトラックに乗せてあげて
さっと持って連れて行くんですよ
この人はそうじゃない
だから いろんな有名なお寺で
主役はこのゾウさんなんですね
だから一つのお寺でお祭りやったら
いくらなんでも歩いて次のお寺のお祭りに行くんです
だから ゾウが行く道っていうのは
人々は待って並んでいて
それから前に警察がちゃんと車に乗って道路を開けてもらったり
後ろからもちゃんと警備の政府でしょうに
で なんとなくそうなっているのは自然に
別に大臣命令 大統領命令ということでもないんです
なんとなく人間が軍隊人であろうが誰であろうか
あのゾウさんにすごい頭を下げて礼をする
それは知りませんんだけど
感動するんですね だから他のゾウの場合は
ちゃんと餌とか探してあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
あのゾウさんが人が行く場合はもうみんな知ってます
今日はこの時間 昼間 このところにいるでしょうと
午後はどのところにいるでしょう
全部用意しているんです
みんな喜んで 食べる時間になりますよ
ゾウが通る時はちゃんと美味しい食べるものを用意して待っているんです
何らよくわからない 私も同じ国の人間だから
やっぱり感動するんですよ
もう 車通るところだったら
私も一回二回会ったんだけど
やっぱり車止めて 止まれ
止まれ 止まれとじーっと見ているんです
だからこのこの特色は何なのかで
注釈書では何も情報なかったんですね
だから私は自分の個人的な主観的な経験を喋っただけで
ただのゾウじゃないゾウもいるんですよ
なんかみんな感動させちゃって
人間の前でも王様の気分
王様になってしまっちゃうという
人間が喜んでお世話するという性格を持ってるゾウもね
いることはいる  ついでに面白いながらくだらない話をしますけど
あのスリランカでゾウの孤児院があるんですね
2つ  3つぐらいあります
一般人に見ることできる場所も
一般人は遠くから見てもいいんだけど
全く連絡してはいけない孤児院もいろいろありますね
それはそれでいろいろな考えであってね
一般人が見て触ってできるゾウさんたちは決して森に戻れないんです
ドメスティックですね
いわゆる しょうがない
で 野生で迷子になったゾウさんを見つけたら
もう野生の環境で孤児院があるんですね
だから決まってる一人二人しかお世話しないんですね
で 観光客はお金払って見ることできるんだけど
決まってる場所があって
遠くから見るしか許されないんです
いわゆる人間と人間の匂いはつけないようにしておいて
できるだけゾウさんたちも野生の匂いにしてあげて
一人前になってくると野生に戻ってあげるという
そういう場所もある この一般人がよく行ったり来たりする
このコロンボの地下鉄となる孤児院で
また象王のようなゾウさんがいるんですね
そう こうのような 見るとびっくりする
立派な象牙もあって すべて象牙がきちんとバランス整えてすべて
しかし 残念ながら野生で撃たれちゃって
目が見えないんですね
目が見えないということもあまりよくわからない
すごいかっこよくいるんですね
そこで このその地方に住んでいる人々は
仕事に行く前に いろんな所に行く前に
とにかく何とかしてあのゾウを見て手を合わせるんだそうです
何やってるのかと やっぱり朝目に入ったら手を合わせたくなるようなゾウさんなんです
よくわからない 私も一回二回行っても
結構長い時間 あのゾウさんのそばにいたんですね
で まあだからそういうのは珍しい
国に 例えばゾウがいる国でって
インドとかスリランカとかね
タイとかはね でもそんなにたくさんいないんですね
珍しいということで得がたいぞ
だからハッピーラタナ像法ですね
これがすごいやとこのおじたちが言ったんですね
2番目 アッサラタナッパとバハをドゥルルボローカスミン
これは馬法ですね 馬法
魔法 どう読むかわからないんだけど
とにかく漢字当てただけで
馬は馬の漢字で宝物の漢字を当てただけで
こんな漢字あるかもして知らないし
だから読み方も私はわかりません
魔法と言ったってもおかしいしね
馬法と言ったってまた変でしょうしね
要するに馬 まあ日本語で言えば馬の宝物
大和言葉で理解できます
馬の宝物  私にはそんなに馬とは経験ないんですけど
まあ馬も私のこと嫌いですよ
動物の中で私のスマナサーラのこと嫌いと思ってるのは馬だけなんですね
だから私はこいつら大嫌いと思わなくちゃあかんなと今悩んでいるところなんです
私は嫌いじゃない 馬は好きですけどもね
馬の中でもやっぱり圧倒される馬がいるんですね
この性格の場合は 馬の方が人間がすごく詳しいんですよ
馬はそれぞれの性格 人格を持っている
だからそれに合わせて調教しなくちゃいけない
いわゆる馬に従うんだよと
馬は人間に従うっていうことはないんです
背中に乗せてあげるかあげないかは馬が決めるんです
そういうことで 公園なんか子供たちに触れ合いパークなんかでも誰だって乗れるポニーとかはいるんですね
それはその性格で まあ誰だって乗っちゃえという感じでいるポニーですね
馬って難しいですよ そこで馬の中でも堂々たる
圧倒される どうしても手を合わせたくなるような馬もいるんだよと
まあ一応 馬の宝物 宝物の馬に言うためには
どんな特色があればいいかどうかってありますけど
まあ今日はそういう情報を探す暇はなかったし
探ったからって何の役にも立たないですね
まあただ単純で 馬を見たら
え？すごいと思える なんとなく手を合わせたくなるような威力のある馬だと思ってください
それが 2番目  3番目の得がたいものはマニラタナッパとバハをドゥルルボローカスミン
これは訳できない 宝石という宝物だ
宝石って？だからパーリ語でマニっていうのは宝石
ラタナっていうのは宝石なんですね
どう訳すればいいかよくわからないんです
だから宝石の中の宝石なんです
そういう風に言った方がわかりやすい
たくさんの宝石があるところで
これが宝石になっちゃうんですね
だからそれには大きさ
それからこのディフェクトという全くないこと
リフレクションとか いろいろ宝石の価値を入れるいろんな計算がありますよ
光がどうやって反射してくるのか
中 いろんな成分入ってますから
不純物当然入ってますね
だから極力不純物が全くない
ありえないね 宝石って自然のミスがたまってたまってあるものだからね
だからもし不純物ではなくて
純な宝石を作っている化学物質だけでできているものが見つけたら
もうこれは宝石の王様なんですね
宝石の宝石になっちゃうんです
で こういうマニラという宝石
で 見つかるかも 日本で宝石ないんだけどね
ミャンマーでもスリランカでもインドでもいろいろ宝石出る場所があってね
まあ掘ったら見つかるかも
4番目は皆様笑っちゃうかも
イッティラタナッソパトバハヴォドゥルラブローカスメン
宝物なる女性 だからそれっていうのは女といくらでも男一人
女一人ぐらい世の中でいますね
五分五分 で みんなまあただの男
ただの女なんですよ その中でまあかっこいい男もいて
すごい美しい女もいるんですけど
まあ結構いるんで その中であえてこれは宝物やっていう女が現れるんですね
要するに誰だって惚ってしまうような女性なんです
見たら体が止まってしまう
そういう女性ももう百万人に
あるいは千一千万人に一人ぐらい生まれてくる可能性あります
そこら辺にあるわけじゃないんです
だから 皆様の人生で 私の人生で一人も見たことがないかもしれません
でも いろんな人を見てきたんだから
この年寄って 今もうそろそろ死ぬ時期になったのに
やはりその中でなんとなく圧倒される人間に出会ったことありますね
なんかちょっことビビっちゃうというかね
怖くてビビるんじゃなくて
あのオーラでなんとなく
そのちっちゃい頃 お坊さんもいたんですね
やっぱりなんか お坊さんの部屋
ちょっと覗いでいるんでしょうかとか
見たくなっちゃうんです
はい そこでこの女性の宝物
だから当然手に入らないし
現れたら まあこれはもう誰のOKの行くかことわからなくなっちゃうし
まあ同時にその場合は性格も関係ありますね
性格的にも女性で見たら誰だって体がフリーズしてしまっちゃうという
これは女であろうが男であろうが関係ないんです
それぐらいの姿なんです
見たら誰だってフリーズしちゃうという
そういうふうな女性がいれば
これがいがたい難しい
珍しいものだとこの王子たちが言ったんですね
4番 5番はもっとわからなくなるんですね
ガハッピラタナッソパートバウォドゥルラブロカスメン
ガハッティっていうのは宝物である
この孤児 財家の人々 だからこのグループは王子たちだから
王子たちのお世話するというかね
いろいろ大臣の仕事 あれやこれやと頼む孤児の人々いるんですね
その中でこの人なら抜群
もう完璧 何でもいいっていうふうな財家の孤児が入れ
財家って言ったらおかしいね
孤児ですね 宝物だと だからその場合は財力
知識 影響力 判断能力 いろんなそろって
それからすごく謙虚であること
王様のことなら何でもしっかりやってあげるとか
いろんな特色あったでしょうね
いわゆるあっと驚かせるような孤児
再婚の人というね この宝物 5つは得がたいものである
ドゥルルルロカス この世の中で得がたいものであると
えらくお互い議論する
だから議論したでしょ？どんなってどんな形でしょうかと
宝石の場合は 宝物 宝石はどんなものでしょうかとかね
いろんな物語やら あの昔物語話やら
いろいろ持ってきて喋ってたでしょうね
うるさくて そこでの見張りに入れた人々が
遠くじーっと見ているんですね
ブッダと弟子比丘たちが来るのかと
来たら まあ見たんですね
見てさっさと王子たちもうお釈迦様見え見えましたよと
今来ているんだよと 言ったら
この若いグループは 王子たちグループはしっかりと見て
お釈迦様を迎えに準備をして待っていて
このサーランダとチェーチェですね
その場所で丁寧に おそらくお釈迦様を歓迎するために待っていたでしょうね
あちらで 先に行って ウェルカムしようと
そこをやったんですね
で やったらお釈迦様はなんのことなく入って
お釈迦様が座るところに座って
お釈迦様はこういう質問をするんですね
君たち 今まで何を喋っていたの？今私が入ったんだからね
あなたたちの会話も中断する羽目になったでしょ
この今までどんな話で
どんな話をしていたのか
どんな話が中断することになったのかと
お釈迦様がこの王子たちに聞くんですね
それお釈迦様のすごい性格なんで
すごい偉い 偉いんだけど
いつでも相手と同じレベルで喋ったりする
何の話しているの？と聞くんですね
そこで経典省略しましたけど
リッチョイ王族がお釈迦様に明確にお釈迦様
我々はこの得がたいものについてディスカッションしていますよと
ああ そう それで結論は？結論は得がたいものが 5つありますと
言って そう 法の話やら
馬の宝物の宝物になる馬の話やら
宝石の宝石の話やら 宝物になる女の話やら
宝はなるべき孤児の話やらするんですね
お釈迦様に うるさかったでしょうね
それでお釈迦様思ったのは
この連中は欲に溺れているんだと
欲に関するものしか考えてないんだと
だからお釈迦様と政府の関係というのは
お釈迦様はすべて叱っちゃうんですね
だから国に対してお釈迦様が師匠なんですね
だからお釈迦様に叱られたとかね
ありがたがるんです だから経典は丁寧に省略して書くんだけどね
お釈迦さん けしからんお前らはと言ったかも
欲のことしかお前ら頭にないんですか？とかね
それで町な考えないとかいろいろ怒ったかも
言って あの 俗世間が考える珍しいもの
得難いものなどは 実は珍しいものでも得難いものでもありませんと
それは説明しましたね
前 私も我々は得難いものとはありがたいレアもので
本当はガラクタでしょ
なんで役に立たん あの 1000万
3000万円になる切手まであるでしょ
だからなんですかね こんなちっちゃい紙
それで条件がありますよ
1000 1000万  1 1000万ぐらいの価値ある切手だったら
あのあの あの あれ 切るところあるでしょ
あのまるまるまるあるとね
あれはぴったしでなければいけませんね
曲がったりしてはいけません
そこで昔から何か糊塗っちゃうでしょ
それは全くその通りでなければいけません
だからそういうものを持ってるという人は
すごい丁寧に扱う 手で触りませんよ
あのギザギザところでちょこっとでも曲がったらアウトだからね
結局ガラクタでしょ  1000万で売ったからって
買った人に何か役に立つ？だからお釈迦様もお前はガラクタでしょうにと
この 5つは この 5つはブッダから見たらガラクタかもしれませんだけど
現代人にもこれほどレアなものは考えられませんね
誰かさんのサイン入った野球バットとか
何だあんなのは  40分ぐらいサインしてくれていたらサインしてくれるんだから
しかし あの宝物の女を考えてください
なかなかないんです あのミスワールドとかいるでしょ
あれっていろんなからくりでいろんな裏の手を回しちゃって
人を選ぶんであって 決して美しい女性を選ぶわけじゃないんです
いろんな政治的な判断するんです
そこから住人があって
この人も 100点 この人みんな 100人の住人いるんだけど
政治的にアメリカの利益になる国の人を選んだりする
アメリカでいれば 80点取る人は 1 になるんだけど
100点のほうをみんな嫌いますけど
そうでない場合は まあ日本でもなんかある女性がミスは日本人に批判されるんですね
ハーフであると まあそういうことだから
だからまあ私もテレビなんかで見たんですけど
あんなもうフリーするほど女じゃないね
まあそこら辺ね よく見かける
よく見かける女でしょう
結局は ちょっと精密に見ると
まあ顔の形いいかも 髪の形がいいかも
足手足の形がいいかも
でもそんな大したことないでしょ
結局 だからこのこの経典に出てくる宝物の女性っていうのはね
なかなか何百年に現れるかもわからない
うん だから本当に得難いものの人で考えていたんですね
例えば象の場合は 私の自分の国でも一頭しかいないでしょ
あれほど象さんたちがいる国に
だからよく考えたっていう風に言ってもいいんだけど
お釈迦様割り込んじゃったんだから
くだらんかと こんなのは
何がそれはと いつでも見つかるでしょうにと
世にあらわれる得難いものは 5つあるんです
そこでお釈迦様が別な 5つを紹介するんです
いわゆる聖なる世界 真理の世界で
本当に得難いもの 本当に宝物
本当に信じられないものが 5つありますよ
はい 順番で行きましょう
得がたいもの一 如来 なぜお釈迦様に如来と言うんですかね
名前もあるでしょ？ゴータマ・ブッダとかね
シッダッタ・ゴータマね
しっかりした名前は だからちゃんと母親がいて
父親がいて もう国がいて
もう全部家族がいて 普通の人間の一人なんですね
それでいつかお釈迦様に如来というふうな言葉で言うようになったんですね
タタハタで そこで人間であることなくなっちゃったんですね
人間なんですけど 人間であることはなくなっちゃって
真理の存在になったんです
如来っていうのは この法則
宇宙全体法則 生命の全体的法則から見れば
この存在は違いますよと
如来といえば 宇宙をどこを探しても見つからない
宇宙のすべての法則を乗り越えているということになります
それで真理ということがありまして
涅槃という境地がありまして
それに従っているんだからと如来とも言うんです
だから真理の人 涅槃の人
悟りの人 人間ではない
だからブッダイコール悟りそのものであって
涅槃そのものであって
キリスト教ではわかりやすい天国そのものであって
キリストの方々は死んだったらどこかどこか行きたいでしょ
イスラム教だったら食い物いっぱいあるところで
女がいっぱいいるところに行きたいでしょ
だからそういう宗教で妄想する天国
天界 園 なんとかなんとかですね
だから我々は仏教迷信ないんだから
我々は解脱 涅槃っていうところ
境地を目指していて で
ブッダとはそのものなんです
だからそれがものすごい世の中で珍しい得がたいものなんです
タタガタサアラハトサンマサンブッダサパータバウォドゥルルボロカスミン
如来であり 阿羅漢であり
正等覚者でありが 現れることはこの世で実に得がたいものです
一人しか現れません そこで現れたら
神々であろうが 梵天であろうが
人間であろうが 幸せになります
みんなの目覚めることになります
みんなを導く みんなの師匠であり
生命はブッダに如来に手を合わせるんではなくて
ブッダには手を合わせるべき存在は一切ないんです
だからこれって宇宙スケールで考えなくいけない
例えば宇宙って無限にあるかも
我々は知らないしね でも自分たちの惑星とかね
太陽系考えちゃうと あまりにもあるでしょ
そんなものは宇宙に それだったら太陽は 1 万個ぐらい数えたら
1個 2つぐらい惑星ができちゃって
生命あるところはあり得る
だからそこら辺で 8,040 万人ぐらいの人間住んでいる宇宙体がありますよと仏教教典なんかにだらだらと書くんだからね
仏教徒にとっては宇宙
地球外生命っていうのは全然どうったことはないんです
当たり前だと こちらよりそちらたくさんいるんだよと
だから この宇宙全体的な生命として見たら
たった一人が正統学者として現れるんです
大乗仏教で言っているような誤解じゃない
どこでもブッダ ブッダとみんなブッダという風な
それはポリティカルレリジオンで
宗教ポリティカルに見ればいい考えですけどね
人間の差別がなくなりますからね
だから大乗仏教の考え方にはそれなりの価値があるんです
人間みんな仏様ですよと
言ったら差別することはなくなりますけど
でも嘘で固めてもね 嘘で道徳を言ったっても意味がないんですね
だから価値がないわけじゃないんだけど
まあまあそれほどということになるんですね
本当は一人しか現れないんです
だからブッダは阿羅漢であると
だから阿羅漢第 1号ですね
ブッダは 阿羅漢でのこと
すべての存在に依存することはなくなっちゃった
いわゆる依存しちゃうと離れちゃう
依存しないと離れちゃうでしょ
依存すると離れないんですね
我々は自分の肉体にカッコ悪いんですよ
肉体に依存しているんで
あまりにもかっこ悪い
臭い 肉体に依存しているんだから
見えるもの 聞こえるものに依存している
依存したって間違いなく本当に依存してないんです
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
味わえるもの 体で触れるものに依存しているんですね
他のものあるとも知らない
だから依存したっても
ものすごく立場がタチが悪いんですよ
で 天国に依存すると言ったっても
それは自分自身の妄想に依存しているだけで
天国の経験ないんだからね
神を信仰していますと言ったっても
実際は自分の妄想を信仰しているんです
だって神を体験したことがないんだからね
誰も 私は私は魂を信じていますと言ったっても
バカ以外何でもないんです
あなた自分の魂を知っている？経験したことがある？発見したことあるってないんですね
ただ観念だけあるかも
ですから 我々の束縛っていうのは本当にタチが悪くて
恥ずかしくて もうなんだこりゃっていうぐらいの束縛を我々は持っている
阿羅漢っていうのは束縛全部なくなっちゃったんです
依存がなくなったんですね
だからものすごい珍しくて
あり得ない存在になるんです
ブッダは阿羅漢なんですね
はい それ第1 本当に得がたいもので
珍しいもので 宇宙に一回しかこの宇宙時間で事件で事件タイムスペースでは今のね
5人現れるんだと言ってますけど
それも伝説でよくわからない
お釈迦様は 4番目でもう一人が現れたら
このスペースタイムは消えちゃうんです
まあそれは私にとっては何も喋れません
伝説に基づいて説法することは私は個人的にしません
だから一応現代人の知識で把握できる範囲で話をリミットしています
で 我々は歴史的なお釈迦様のことは知っている
しかし 人類の歴史の中で信じられないんですね
こんな人が現れたっていうことは
あんな時代で 喋った言葉は未だにどうにもならない宝物で
ここまで科学を発展しているのに
今人間の役目が終わっちゃって
すべて IT の機械に世界を管理される
我々はなんとなく動物園の動物みたいな状態に将来なるでしょ
飼育係に管理されている動物たち
それから将来はロボットたちが世界支配して
銀行やらすべて病院やら全部ロボットたちがやっていて
人間は動物園の動物のように飼育係のお世話で餌くれたら食べて
治療してくれたらいただいている存在になっちゃう
将来は だからそこまで人類が成長して
それからドカーンと退化するところまで今ピークになってるんですね
ピークですけど もうどんどん人間の能力が退化していくんです
機械にすべて任せちゃいますからね
機械に任せるしかない
人間の知識というのは曖昧
中途半端 いい加減で当てにならない
何頼んでもどこかで失敗するんです
100%パーフェクトで何もできないんですね
ヒューマンエラーっていうのは当然どこでも現れる
例えば今日私は完璧に喋ろうと思ったとしてもありえないんですね
だからデジタルにどんどんボタンタッチをする
例えば なんで私は今 PowerPoint スライド使ってますかね
こちらで白板があって字書こうと思ったら
字が間違うわ 忘れているわ
かっこ悪いわ 読める字もあって読めない字もあるわ
いろいろトラブルでしょ
これだったらデジタルで正しい字を出してくれる
何も文句言えない この阿羅漢の漢の漢字が私は気に入らんとか言える？言えないね
そのまま従うしかないんです
これは人が書いたならば
阿羅漢のアーとアはかっこいい
羅はすごい見事 漢はちょっと
なんかバランスが崩れたと言えるでしょ
人間書いたならば そういうわけで
どんどん我々は人間が重役から脇役になって
脇役からいらん存在になっていく
だから今時代のピークの方になっていて
どうか将来わかりませんだけどね
で わからないんだけど
それは置いておいて なのにブッダの智慧は
ブッダは 唯一太陽のように輝く存在なんですね
だから珍しい ありがたい
得難いというならば 第一ブッダですね
如来ですね だからここで如来
尊きという言葉を使ったのは
それが理由なんです ブッダはタタガタであることがありがたいことです
人類の中で一人しか現れないし
天人の師匠ですね お釈迦様は
はい  2番目に行きましょう
説法師と私がなんかもっといい単語あればいいなと
今日 教示という言葉もあったんだけどね
あまり軽く見ないでください
この説法師という言葉
なんか教示教示する師匠というね
タタガタボーディサットダンマミニアシデシタデシタ
プッグルドゥルルル ローカスマイン
これは私のいい加減な訳で
如来が説かれた法と律を他人に教えられる人は
この世で得難い存在です
そこで如来が何かわかったんです
すべては何かではなくて
すべてわかったんです
生命のシステム 宇宙のシステム
両方わかったんです 宇宙がどのように現れて
どのように消えるのかどうか
最近読んだ論文で 仏教では地球の人間が猿から進化するとか書いてないんですね
神がアヴァスターの神々がいて
神々もじわじわじわと地面に住むようになっちゃって
どんどん退化して人間になった
退化して ある論文でお釈迦様のあの説教は科学的に正しいんだと
いて すっごいいろんなデータだって書いてあったんだけど
で 斜めにしか読んでないし
斜めな人格だからね もうどうしても
で そちらにあるのは このただこの地球の上のことじゃなくて
この ソーラーシステム
もっと全体的なことをおっしゃっているんだと
だから 地面の上に生命が現れたことではなくて
このどうしても仏教ではユニバースという単語を使うんだから
宇宙というね だから今
この宇宙の現れを書いているんだ
そこで最初はもうエネルギーだけで
激しい光のエネルギーが行ったり来たり
行ったり来たりしている
そこに生命のエネルギーがあったんではなくて
地球の中でも最初は真っ暗で
ものすごい稲妻 光ばっかりでしたからね
そこで物質的な生命に変化したという話もあります
それを実験もして成功もしています
はい これは余計な話で
そこで如来は真理をわかったんです
この真理をそこでもない人間に喋られるならば
誰かに説明してあげることできるならば
これってすごいんです
それが珍しいとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
それが得難いんだと 皆
説法ぐらいは誰にだってできるですと思っているでしょう
それじゃないんです  ただバナナのたたき売りやみたいなね
説法は誰だってやっています
あんなの説法じゃないでしょ
本当の説法というのは
人の心が変わるんですよ
しかし 洗脳しません マインドコントロールしません
無明の闇が破れるんです
だからお釈迦様自身も自分の弟子たちの中で教授上手な教授
教えることをできるお坊さんたちのことをあえて褒めるんです
いろいろ位まであげるんです
おそらくお釈迦様のお心の中にあったのはサーリプッタ尊者のことやとは思いますけどね
またたくさんいましたし
面白いっていうのは この
食べて遊んで寝て もう子供作ってふざけて生きて死ぬだけの興味しか持ってないでしょ
人間は 何食うのか 何を着るのか
誰と結婚して成功するのかと
子供が生まれたら まあその一生懸命もう宇宙が子供だと思っちゃって
こいつの奴隷になって
それで年取って死ぬ 全てできなくなっちゃって
それしか興味ないでしょ？アメリカで最近流行ってる音楽は何ですか？とかね
今一番ヒットしている歌手は誰でした？と
日本にいつ来るのかとかね
それで興味がある 今流行っている振り付けは何でした？とかね
だからもうもう動物となって何食うか
どこに寝るのかということしかもう興味ない人類に
だからギリシャ哲学時代でも
哲学を語る人々は頭イカれてると言うでしょ
変人だとかね あの人に捕まったらもう何時間も捕まって喋らせ
話を聞かせられるんだから
逃げる逃げると あの人に挨拶したいんだけど
挨拶ちょっとあんたこれ悪い
これ悪い 愛しない これ言われます
いやいやですと それは人間の本当の姿なんですよ
地球はどんな国でもね
真理は聞きたくない 任人がヨーロッパに行ったら
日本の簡単にできる日本料理でも教えたらものすごくウケますよ
もう じゃあせっかくスイスに行ったんだから
じゃあ瞑想の仕方教えてください
誰も来ない では座禅の仕方教えてあげますとかね
連れてる案内している人も
私はじゃあやってください
私ちょっと用事があるから逃げるんです
そんな世界ですよ これはもう地球でどこでも同じことです
それで人間に教えられる能力があった人が現れたら
これは並大抵の力じゃないんです
認識次元を破れるように喋らなくちゃいけない
皆様方は眼耳鼻舌身意があるんだけど
何も見てないと証明しなくちゃあかんのです
目があっても見てないよ
あなた方は 耳があってもあなた方は聞いてないんだよと
でも見えてるで あれ見えてない
自分の頭の中で画像を作っちゃったんです
自分勝手な画像 聞いてない
耳がギチギチゴチャゴチャになっちゃうと音が触れちゃって
自分の脳みその中で自分好き勝手な音を作るんです
だから自分の世界 厳格に閉じ込められているんだよと
それを明確に説明して開けなさいよと
眼耳鼻舌身を オープンユアセンセスというメッセージは
できませんよ 言ったらバカにされます
目がある人は あんた目くらで見えないね
あんたにもと言ったらバカにされるでしょ
そういうことで 欲があるから生きてるのに
この人欲を捨てようと言うんだから
あんた病院に行った方がいいんじゃない？と言われます
だからブッダの教え 如来が発見したわかった真理を人に喋れる人っていうのは
もう奇跡の人間なんです
だから世の中では仏教徒はたくさんいるんだけど
ちゃんと喋る人々っていうのはものすごい未だに少ないんです
色々マスコミ向かってもう人気の説法した時はいますよ
本物はいません  3番目に行きます
3番目の得難いもの理解者
タタガタプロディサダンマヴィニヤスデーシタス
ヴィンニャータプッガラドゥルラパローカスマ
如来が悟った悟って他人に説かれた法と律を理解できる人が世に得難い存在です
これ当たり前になっちゃうんです
だって教える人も珍しいでしょ？それを聞いてわかったならば
なおさら珍しいでしょ
あのわかった人々 自分で次元破っちゃったんです
認識の殻破ったんです
イソギンチャクの生活知ってますね
自分いる場所からまるっきり動かないんですね
だからイソギンチャクに説法したら
世界について教えてくれと
イソギンチャクは何を教えてくれる？ちゃんと妄想したらね
イソギンチャクにも喋ることはできると
それで我々も何か機械を作って
そこでイソギンチャクに対応する
なんか世の中について教えてくださいと
何を教えてくれますかね
イソギンチャクは 妄想できるでしょ？だから我々の人生は同じで
眼耳鼻舌身からデータを入れて
自分の中でなんかごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃというスープを作って
もう臭い幻想を作って
それが世界やと思っているんですね
だから人と喋ると 人は自分の頭の中でごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ回転されている妄想を喋ってるんです
真理喋ってないんです
例えば食べる物の場合は
うどんよりラーメンじゃなくてそばの方がいいですよとかね
自分勝手なことを言ってるだけで
この音楽よりこの音楽聴いてみて
この方がいいやと それは自分のことでしょうに
自分聞いたら自分がそこで妄想できちゃったんだから
他人にもこの歌を聞いたら泣けるぜと言っちゃうでしょ
そう言われると私もその歌を聞くんです
泣けません 腹が立つんです
なんだこれやと だから我々は喋るために
自分 自分自身の主観の世界
妄想の世界 うるさいんですよ
だから人が喋ると ついでに言いますけど
仏教では喋るなよと言ってるでしょ
できるだけできるだけ修行は無言でやってくださいと
だから昔は 200人お坊さんたちが住んでいたっても声はないんです
誰も喋っていない いらない
喋るというのは自分の妄想がギャーギャーと発表することでしょうに
妄想だらけで妄想は音声にもしちゃうと
妄想している自分自身でもうるさいなのに
自分の心の中で余裕がないのに妄想に時間取ってしまっちゃうんです
だから朝ごはん作る暇がなくなっちゃうんです
妄想に時間過ぎちゃって朝寝坊しちゃうんです
24時間足らないんでしょ
20時間足らないっていうのは妄想しているからなんです
だって妄想じゃない 死ぬまでやったっても終わらないでしょ
自分自身でも妄想でうるさくてしょうがないのに
これ音声データにしたらどうなる？音声バイトとして空気を振動させる
もう耐えられないと思いますよ
だから修行者は喋れないんです
で それで頭よくなりますよ
例えば人が私のところに水を持ってくる
私はありがとうございます
ご丁寧に水を持っていただいて
誠に感謝いたします 何ですか
あの言葉は うるさいだけで言わない
喋らなくても挨拶できるでしょうに
置く場所に困っていれば
指でちょっと見せることできるでしょうに
だからギリギリ喋らないことにして
どうしても音声にしなくちゃいけない時だけ音声にするということをやっていたんですね
はい それで私は言っているのは
そういう巨大な殻で自分を覆って
中で第三次世界戦争のように妄想ばっかりしかやっている人に喋れということはいかに難しいかと
それで喋ったら この人分かったらどうするんですかね
ありえないことなんです
だから説法したからといって聞いた人へと仏教をわかったら
え？びっくりなんです
あんたわかったの？珍しいよと
人は仏教を理解しないよと
だからブッダブッダの教えを聞いて
もし皆様方に何かわかったならば
本当にもう追い出さなくちゃいかん
この俗世間の人間じゃないんです
もう人間に理解できるはずがないんです
これは だからブッダの教えを理解できたならば
これは得がたい存在です
あと 2つありますから
早く行きましょう あの報告は 3つだけですけど
私は 2つ繋げたんです
得がたいものを読ん タターガタプロディッサタダンマウィナヤスデーシタッサ
ヴィンヤータッサ ダンマヌダンマパティパンノプッガロドゥルラボローカスマイン
意味は簡単です 理解された法と律に従って実践する人は
この世で得がたい存在です
そこで珍しく ブッダが悟った真理がある
でも これは語る能力ある人がいない
そこで珍しく語れる能力ある人が現れる
語る っても人間に理解できない
たまに理解できる人も現れる
これ珍しい 次に理解できても
これやってみようとすると
なおさら数少ないんです
ではやってみると そういうことで
例えば欲は良くないわ
怒ることは良くないでしょ？知ってるでしょ？煩悩は良くないというようなことも知ってるでしょ
知ってるんだけど やってる？やってない
それやる気にはなってない
煩悩をなくす気にはなってない
だから煩悩をなくす気になったら
執着をなくす気になったら
これまたすごい珍しいことです
ものすごい得難いことなんです
だからこの５つにしたのは
皆様にもやっぱり 3番目
4番目の珍しい人間にはなれます
私は 2番目の珍しい人間も期待しています
皆様の中から仏教の真理を語れる才能の人々が現れたらありがたいなと思っているんです
で  1と2ができなくても
3 4は皆様誰にだってできるとは思います
いわゆるいわゆる世に珍しい人間になるんです
世に得難い人間になるんです
これで一般的に考えても
地球上どれぐらい人間がいる？じゃあその中で何人仏教徒がいる？こんなわずかでしょ
アジアに仏教徒がいると言っても
あんなちっちゃなミャンマー
小さなタイ スリランカ
ラオス インドネシアにかなわないでしょ？面積で人口で
仏教じゃないでしょ インドはどうですかね
ほとんどないんですね
仏教徒は インドの人口は
だから仏教徒であることもものすごく珍しいことで
その中でも真理わかっている人々は理解している
頭で タイ人は 99%仏教ですけど
ちょっと喋ってみて 仏教わかってるのかと
全くわかってないんです
例えば私がタイ語を喋れませんだから
いくら衣を着ていても
仏教だとお坊さんと理解できないんです
平気で聞くんです あなたイスラム教？どんな宗教と聞くんです
ひっちゃらけ だから理解レベルは
そこで理解した人々の中でも
ちゃんと瞑想を実践している人々はなおさら珍しいでしょう
だからトランプさんの直々サインした紙をもらったよりは珍しいんですよ
仏教を実践する人々は
最後になります 最後はもう仏教とは関係ないことなんですね
だから 4つ仏教に関わるもの
だからブッダは真理を語っている
どんな科学者よりも科学を語っているが
世の中で極端な少数派なんです
広げません 政治的権力を使っちゃうと
宗教として広がりますよ
出ます 真理として広がります
日本も基本的に仏教の国なんです
政治的なんです 昔の 実際やってみようとすると
日蓮みたいな連中が現れるんです
頭イカれていて 南無妙法蓮華経と言いなさいと
あるいはナンマンダと言いなよ
これ別な人 親鸞ですね
実際実践しようと思うと
あんな程度の人々は現れてくるんです
真剣真面目に無常とは何ぞや
因果法則とは何ぞやと
貪瞋痴はいかに生まれるのか
貪瞋痴を抑えるためにどうすればいいのかどうか
慈しみはどう実践すればよいのかと語る人は
人間の仏教史の中にないでしょ
その代わりに歎異抄という本があるんです
私は読まない 読みたくもない
はい そういうわけで  1から4まで
本当に珍しいんです 隕石が地球ここら辺まで来て
また上に戻るような感じなんです
宇宙からものすごいバカでかい隕石がザーッと来て
気が変わったとまた出て行ったと
それぐらいの4項目は珍しい
だからといってなんで語るのかというと
やってよと こんなに珍しくて
しかしこれが真理であって
苦しみがなくなるんだよとのメッセージなんです
はい 最後の 5番目に行きます
カタニュー カトエジー プッガラ ドゥルラブ ローカスマイン
恩を知り 恩を感ずる人の
これはコピーペーストで
この訳だけコピーペーストです
ゲン何でしたっけ？これは
権限 えっ？権限は世において得難いものです
あ これはそんなに皆様に理解難しくはないんです
日本文化でも恩を知る
感謝の気持ちという言葉がありますね
あれに似ているんです
だったら日本中みんな得難い存在になりますね
ちょっと引っ掛けはあるんです
あんたやっているのか
感謝の気持ちで生きて
あんた実際やっている？人に言うんじゃなくて
だから私は日本文化では感謝という言葉がすごく動いています
恩を知るという言葉もよく私の恩師ですとかは言いますね
でも本当に恩を感じているのかというと
そうでもないんですね
感謝しまくっている人々いるんだけど
なんか変に感じる あんたこの人変でしょうと
だからちょっと問題なんです
では ブッダは人類の法則を語るんだから
生命の法則を語るんだから
そのスタンスから説明します
これは日本人に限った話じゃないんです
生命の話です 生命というのはわがままなんです
ゴキブリであろうが 犬であろうが
日本人であろうが アメリカ人であろうが
神であろうか 関係ないんです
戦争であろうが関係ないんです
生命でしょ 生命はわがままなんです
だからといって生命に悪口言えないんです
各生命は自分の命を繋ぐために必死で頑張らなくちゃあかんです
ただで 自動的に生きる世界は天国でもないんです
キリスト教とイスラム教は相当勘違いしています
すべてフルフルオートモードで生きられると
それ自体最悪でしょうに
食いたくなったら食いたいものをどんどん口にオートで入るんだったら
気持ち悪いでしょうに
なんだ イスラムの方々は自爆テロやるんですかというと
自分思ったぐらいの処女たちが天国でいただくんだと
相当気持ち悪くなると思いますよ
なんか女の子とイメージした途端現れるんだから
だから相当頭イかれてるんですよ
実際はそうじゃないんです
どんな生命も あの命をつなぐために
必死です もうセミたちがもうもうそろそろ亡くなったでしょ
見てください  1ヶ月間
どれほど頑張ったのかと
生きるために 今は空しか残ってないね
暇がないんです これは神であっても同じことなんですよ
それで地獄に落ちたら
地獄の生命だけは早く死にたいと思っているんです
だって極端に苦しいでしょ
それでその人々は死なないんです
どうですかね 考えてください
自分が自殺したくて 首にロープを回してしっかり結んで
もうこれからドカンと飛び降りる
それで首でぶら下がっているんだけど
死なない 気持ちいいね
呼吸できない 喉が壊れている
でも死なない あれ 崖から飛び降りる
ビルから飛び降りると
それで肋骨がゴチャッとなっちゃって
手足全部つぶれちゃって
足があちらで この足 他の足があちらで
でも死なないと 恐ろしいでしょ
地獄はそういうところなんです
地獄の他の生命体はもう切ったり
のこぎりで切ったり 釜に入れたりすると
これは人間にわかりやすくした物語ですけど
もっとひどいんです 状況は
まあだから人間の世界で考えてください
誰か二人が自分を捕まえて
のこぎりで またのこぎりも真っ赤に燃えているのこぎりですよ
これで切る 切っても死なない
これで切って切って終わると
向こうの上の方が繋がっている
だからそこはそれで だから地獄に落ちた生命が何としてでも死にたいということで頑張らなくちゃいけない
天国に生まれたら ほんのわずかなことで死ぬんです
例えば食事の時間 ずれただけでも死にます
すごくもろいんです だからこそ
例えば我々は 1分呼吸しなかったら死ぬでしょ
その点で困らなくてもいいんです
オートでできているんです
いくらでも空気があるし
体が自動的に呼吸しているし
だから我々は困らないんです
天国にいたら同じことで食事ずれたら死にますけど
それはオートで自動的に起こるんです
はい そういうことで 生命っていうのは生きるために必死なんです
皆様もそうなんです 人に優しく振る舞うとか
そんな余裕ないんです
自分で呼吸しなくちゃいけないし
お風呂に入らなくちゃいけないし
食事しなくちゃいけないし
仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
スケジュールを作らなくちゃいけないし
約束したら約束通り動かなくちゃいけないし
それから家族の中で体の弱い人やら問題持っている人いたら
そこお世話しなくちゃいけないし
大変です そこで論理的に考えてください
生命は自分の命をつなぐために極端に忙しい
だから他人が食ったか食わなかったっていうことは調べる余裕がありません
まず 田舎の親が病気で心臓発作を起こしちゃって
もう入院しているんだけど
東京の会社で仕事してる人はさっさと行けないでしょ
行かなくちゃあかんでしょ
でも行けない そんな簡単に会社は休めない
休んじゃったらわがままで次戻れないとクビになっちゃってってありますから
だから生命っていうのは自分で生きることには必死で忙しい
もう次のポイント どんな生命も他の生命の協力なければ生きられません
あまりにもかわいそうな状態なんです
たくさん無数の他の生命が自分の命をサポートしなくちゃあかんのです
俺は会社で仕事をしてちゃんと給料もらって生きているんだよと
会社って何？他の生命の組織でしょ
会社は日本社会がなければ成り立たないでしょ
アフリカのサハラ砂漠で会社作ったからといってね
何の意味もないでしょ
社会が必要なんです サハラ砂漠でいくらでも砂があるんだから
砂を売る商売を始める
成り立たないね しかし
日本で砂を売る商売を始めたら
売る人 買う人が現れるんです
ですから 命は他の生命がいないと成り立たない
40兆の細胞あると言ったっても
細胞と一個の細胞には一人で何もできない
細胞の中にいるもっと小さな細胞体の生命たちの協力が必要です
よくわかりやすいのはミトコンドリアなんです
ミトコンドリアが細胞を育っているんだからって
ミトコンドリア偉いんですかね
ミトコンドリアにしたっても
他の細胞の中にいるしか方法がないんです
それでわかるでしょ 腸の中でものすごい大量に菌がいないと
土の中でそれなりの水辺なければ
もう野菜は現れません
そういうわけで 神々も梵天も地獄もすべて他の生命の波長がなければ
梵天の場合は波長なんですけど
神々の場合はある程度で
我々の場合は具体的な協力なんです
ここで何か見えない 生命には余裕がない
暇がない しかし 生命は他の生命の協力がないと成り立たない
ない だから全ての生命の義務は感謝の気持ちを持つことでしょう
生かしてくれてありがたいと思うことでしょう
今日 1時間生きることはできました
ありがとうございますと言わなくちゃいけないでしょう
でも そんなこと言う暇がある？感じる暇すらないんです
だから日本で文化的に言うだけで
実際は実行していないんです
これで日本人悪いわけじゃないんです
神も同じ状態なんです
ブッダがその真理を言っているんです
しかし 人間にハイライトしている
恩を知る人っていうのは珍しいんだよと
本当に珍しいんですよ
あなたもよくも余裕あったもんだなと言いたくなっちゃうんです
親に感謝するんだからね
お前は本当によく余裕があることやと言えるぐらい珍しいことなんです
だからブッダはあえてこれやりなさいよと
親に感謝しろよと 親を尊敬しろよと
教師を尊敬しなさいよと
目上の人 徳の場合ですよ
年齢じゃないんです 目の目上の人に頭を下げて尊敬しなさいよと
それやると素晴らしい人間になっていくんです
珍しい人間になるんです
だって余裕がないのに
自分のことで精一杯なのに
だから珍しいんです 各生命は自分のことで精一杯なのに
全くも人のこと 他の生命のこと気になる余裕ないのに
気にしている 感謝しているならば
これは珍しいんです だからお釈迦様これ言ったのは
こんなもんや まあいいやということじゃなくて
やってくださいなんです
とにかく始めて感謝の気持ちを実行しなさいよと
例えば母の日で 電話 1本で花屋さんにあのの
この住所に何花でしたっけね
母の日に使うの カーネーション？カーネーション
10本ぐらい 10本 じゃあまあ 6本でいいんですと
送ってください では 送りに
あの この名前書いてください
あれって何？あれは母侮辱することでしょ？だから西洋文化が皆様に母を侮辱しなさい
父親を侮辱しなさい 敬老
敬老じゃなくて 言葉を漢字に変えなくちゃいけない
あの敬視する敬を書かなくちゃいけないんです
だから あんな原始人の文化
なんで受けるんですかね
なんで 2000年  3000年古い文化を持ってるこちらの教え聞かないんですかね
頭が悪いでしょうね そんな面倒くさいことを言わなくたって
だから母に感謝してよ
父親に感謝してよ 東京で一人で住んでいる人々も
母親電話かけるところまで待てないで
自分で毎日お母さん元気？じゃあ今日私も一日頑張りましたから
お母さんありがとうございますねとかね
そういう風に感謝して生きれば
生きてみれば素晴らしい世界が
幸福な世界が現れてくる
必ず現れますよ だって生きることはいかに苦かと感謝する人がわかるんです
感謝するためにも 恩を知るためにも
大変だと これは結構時間かかる
苦しまなくちゃいかんやと
だから生きること自体やめた方が楽ちんやと
だから存在欲をなくせというブッダの教えに必ず戻るんです
今日の珍しい項目 5つはこれで終了です
ありがとうございます
はい あの このテキストの中で
このブッダが理解した法と律
ダンマビナヤという言葉を使ってたんですね
はい そういうところでダンマビナヤという言葉がありますね
ダンマ ヴィパッサナー
ブッダの教えには普通はダンマとヴィパッサナーというのは日本語に当てると
まあ法と律という風になるんですね
それはあのダンマっていうのは
ただ真理のことですね
真理 真理を知っただけだだけでは何の意味もないんですね
だからどうするのかという次の問題
いわゆる実践が出てくるんですね
例えば地球が丸いとわかったら真理ですけど
どうするのか？どうする必要もないんですね
放っておけばいいんです
しかし ここでブッダは地球が丸いようなどうでもいい話は言ってない
生きるということは何なのかという
これ 宇宙スケールで生きることについて分析して語っているんです
だから生きると言ったら自分が生き物だから
そこで私はどうすればいいっていうことは出てくるんです
またはなんで出てくるのかというと
生きることっていうのはうまくいってないんですね
どんな生命であっても
地球の生命 地球外の生命
人間にわかる生命 人間以外の神々
天国などなどのいかなる生命であってもうまくいってないんです
面白いことは 多宗教で一神教で神様を作っているでしょ？人々は
神様は全知全能と言っても
聖書ぐるっと読んでみたら
神がうまくいってないんです
生命はそんなもんなんです
神様は計画を立てるんだけど
すべてダメになっちゃうんですね
預言者を送ろう送ろう
みんなろくでもない預言者たちで
最後の預言者といって恐ろしい犯罪者送っちゃったんで
モハメッドという すごい情弱を
うまくいってない まとめると
だから生きることはうまくいってない
これ神は関係ないんです
そこで生きる法則を教えたら
じゃあどうすれば？っていうところでブッダがアドバイスするんですね
こうしなさい ああしなさい
あれしなさい これこれ
それがヴィパッサナーなんですね
ティーチングアンドディシプリン
トゥルースアンドディシプリンという風に 2つになるんですね
だからいつでもそのセットで語るんです
それだけ説明は抜けました
それから珍しいと言ってればいろいろありますよ
これだけではなくて これはよく出てくる一つで
人間に生まれることは珍しい
ブッダの教えを聞くチャンスは難しい
いろいろありますね はい
それでは皆様に何か質問あるならばしてください
では マイクを回したいので
ではちょっと先に向こうの真ん中の方に
はい あの 先ほど先生は首を吊ったり電車に飛び込んだりしても生命は亡くならないとおっしゃいました
じゃあ生命は自殺した人はもう亡くなったと思ってましたが
どこへ行ったんでしょうか
誰が？ 自殺した人が  ん？ 首を吊ったり
電車に飛び込んだり 手がちぎれたりした人
生命はそれでも生命は亡くならないと
先ほど え？ 地獄の生命です
あ じゃあここの世の中で死んだ自殺した人の生命はどこへ行くんでしょうか
あんた生命というのは何か物やと思ってるんですかね
生命というのはエネルギーでしょう
エネルギー  はい エネルギーは流れるでしょうに
じゃああんた 今雨が降る時期だからね
稲妻見える？エネルギーでしょ
稲妻消えたら あれどこ行った？落ちたのか探ってみて
だからエネルギーっていうのは変化するの
対数変化する こちらに私がいるっていうのは錯覚であって
ずっとエネルギーが変化するんです
だから変化するエネルギーの交差点だけ
どこか行くんですか？という質問は成り立たないで
これって場所を聞いてるようなものでしょうに
そう思うと もう大変ですね
ならば  それはあなたにはちょっと理解が難しいと思います
忘れてください 困らないこともいいんで
エネルギーはどこに行きますかって質問が成り立たない
もうエネルギーは変わることで成り立つんです
うん まああまり難しくなるんだから
もう質問があると私もあれこれ説明しますからね
分からなくなったらどうしますかね
エネルギーの法則を教えなくちゃいかん
エネルギーっていうのはもう何か変化を起こすことでしょうに
だから変化はどこまでかというと
もうキリがないんです
哲学の本を読んでいる人々は聞いているでしょう
あのどこかのアフリカどこでも
蝶々がパタパタと翼を叩いたら
これはアメリカの竜巻の結果になるんだよとかね
それは間違った話じゃないんです
エネルギーっていうのは対数って変化して変化していくんです
仮に名前をつけただけでね
例えばこれはイスという文字が映っていると嘘でしょうね
ただエネルギーが流れているだけでしょう
仮には文字があるんだと勝手に言ったってもいいんですけど
一時的にね それも  そういうことで
生命っていうのは まあただエネルギーが変化している場所
そこで場所を決めちゃうと生命になる
場所を決めなかったら生命ではなくなっちゃうんです
だから場所が具体的にあるっていうことは
エネルギーの話ではなく
成り立たない そういうわけで
あなたの話はウサギの砂が角が長いか短いかと聞いている質問です
です 答えられないんです
私は地獄の生命は一般的に説明しただけで
死にたい死にたいと思ったらのは死ねない
人間の場合は死にたくないと思っているのに死ぬ
どちらでも苦しい うん
あまり難しいを考えてください
ありがとうございます
よろしくお願いします
えっと 人と話す時に優しい心で話したいと思うのですが
嫌いな人や苦手な人が相手だと
どうしても怒りや嫌悪の気持ちで優しく話すことができません
どうしたらいいのかアドバイスお願いします
だから苦手な人があるというと
あなたの間違いでしょうに
でも なんで私があなたの間違いを正当化しなくちゃいかん
間違いとりっぱですね
あなたとかね それはあなたの問題でしょ
なんであんたに苦手な人がいるんですかね
自分の問題直してくださいよ
うん 私に苦手な人がいる
だからその人はかわいそうでしょうに
私に気に入らない人がいると
相手が被害者でしょうに
だから問題は私にあるでしょうに
だから人と喋ると優しい言葉で喋らなくちゃ
でも苦手な人の場合はあんたの問題で
それはと だから苦手と思ったところに頭が病気なんです
だからそこは直すように頑張ってください
言葉を別に後回しにして
人は生命は苦手やと思わない
生命は慈しむんです 生命ってかわいそうです
偉い生命は一人もいないんです
みんなやっと生きてるだけで
それでも見事に失敗する
みんなやっと生きてるのにうまくいかない
老衰 病気でなるわ 年取るは
死ぬは 家族仲良くいようとみんな頑張ってるんだけど
無駄です それは成り立たない
愛する人々は別れていく
そういう人間を恨む この限りなく苦しんでる人々は
あまりも自分の苦しみの
何て言えば あまりも苦しみを感じて
きゃー嫌だとか泣き叫ぶかも
それは俺に言われたと
なんで勘違いするんですかね
人は自分の苦しみでニコニコとすることはできなくなってる
あなたにしたっても あまりニコニコしないで
ずっとあなたの顔を見ているんだけど
見て覚えているんだけど
いつこれまで私はふざけたことを言っているのに
あんた笑わないでしょ？だからあなたにも相当の生きることは苦しいと思います
そういうわけで いろんな人が自分の人生であまりにも苦しくて
ちょっと変な行動をするかも
それになんだ あなたの態度は悪いやとかね
思うことが私の間違いでしょうに
だから生命は苦しんでいる
生命はやっと生きている
生命には人のことを見る余裕ない
生命にありがとうと言う暇がない
お腹が空いている生命をおにぎり取ってパクッと食ってるんであって
味わう余裕がない あ 美味しいですね
これ作った人 本当に素晴らしく作ったんでしょうとか思う余裕がない
私はこのコンビニのおにぎり買ったらすごくありがたくて不思議なるんですよ
だってあれはピシッと三角形にしてるんだから
私も一回作ろうしたら三角形ではなくて
丸にならない丸い球になっちゃったんです
丸いと言ったらたまに怒られるんです
そこでよう分かったと言って
型を買ってきたんです
腹が立って で 型にご飯詰めておにぎり作ると失敗しました
それでも型から外すとまた壊れちゃったんです
それから諦めて皿にスプーンでご飯作って食べたんです
だから 私にとっては おにぎり...コンビニで売ってるおにぎりを取っちゃうとすごいなと思いますよ
もう だからこれは誰が作ってるか分からないんだけど
この各会社でいろいろあれ
コントラクトでやってるでしょうね
そちらでおにぎりを作る機械があったりして
それからぴったしご飯炊いて
適当な温度で適当な厚さで精密に計算してパチパチとおにぎり作ってるかも
でもこちら余裕がない
あと 30 分しかない 走っていっておにぎり買って
何か飲み物を買って 食べて飲んでまた走るでしょうに
だから感謝ぐらいしようと思っても
その人のその精神的には余裕がないんです
それでこの人気に入らないと
何考えてるんですかね
あの人の服装は気に入らない
あの人の髪型は気に入らない
気に入らない あの人の喋り方は気に入らない
これは私が病気という言葉なんです
だからあなたにアドバイスとして言うというのは
気に入らないということをなくしてください
苦手という言葉はなくしてください
人を苦手と思うのはあなたの問題ですよ
それはあなたの修行です
それを直してください
はい  ありがとうございます
はい では今お持ちしますね
本日は貴重なお話ありがとうございます
歩く瞑想についてお伺いしたいのですが
私は 7月 今年の 7月に長老の初心者瞑想指導を受けまして
ずっと歩く瞑想にチャレンジしているんですが
歩く瞑想で右足を上げる
運ぶ 下ろすというのを繰り返していると
途中でですね 右足を上げるにしても
例えば上げる時に膝を
膝を曲げているんだなとか
足の付け根を運ぶ時には動かしているんだなということに気づいたんですけども
瞑想している時はそういったことにあまり気にしない方が良いのか
気にせずに運ぶ 上げる
運ぶというのを意識した方がいいのか
それともそういったその膝とか足の付け根とかの感覚をに集中
意識を向けた方がいいのかっていうことについてお聞きしたいです
正しいやり方は あなた
私に与えた選択範囲に入ってないんだけど
私に ABC から一つ選んでくださいと言ってるんだけど
正しい答えは A でも B でも C でもないんだけど
では正しい答えを教えて
でもあなた脳ができてないでしょ？理解するために
これは本当に瞑想の質問の場合はいつでもある
ハンディで脳である概念を作ってセットアップして質問するんですね
そうすると こちらのプログラムはその方には入らないんですね
だからできれば頭きれいにして下さい
それから答えます 歩く瞑想は自分でできる範囲でやってください
左足上げる 運ぶ 下ろす
右足上げる 運ぶ 下ろすと
どうしても言葉使わなくちゃいけないという条件があります
ですから 右足の曲がっている左足のなんて言いますか
この右足ではなくて 膝あ
膝曲がっている 腰が上がっていると感じるかも
でもそれに言葉与えようと思っちゃうとどうなる？かなりややこしいことになる
腰も曲がっていて 膝も膝も曲がっていて
では足前に行ってとかね
そうすると 動きと言葉のあれ
調和がなくなるんですね
そこを気をつけてください
気をつけた方がいい それは何て言いますかね
それがその瞑想でよく歩く
それで修行する人はそんなのは感じるんだけど
まあ面倒くさいんだから
左足上げる 運ぶ 下ろす
右足上げる 運ぶ 下ろすと
そこら辺でちょっと集中してみます
感じることはいいんです
感じて勝手に感じるんだから
頼んでもないのに勝手に感じるでしょ
そういう感じで感じておいてください
そちらにも言葉をかけようと思っちゃうと
この流れが壊れるんです
一つのミュージックのオーケストラみたいに思ってください
だからそこで演奏している人々は
なんかここら辺かゆくなっちゃったか
そうすると時間間に合わないでしょ
そこで指揮者がこう信号出したら
こいつはバイオリン弾かなくちゃあかんでしょ
ちょっと待って はい 次
ありえないんです そういうことで
上げる 運ぶ 下ろす 上げる
運ぶ 下ろす リズムに乗って頑張ってください
しかし 感覚はそれだけではない
お尻を感じるわ 膝を感じるわ
踵を感じるわ それから足の動きに乗って体の繊細細胞たちの流れで感じるわ
いろんなものを感じる
それは集中力が出てくると見えてきます
それにも言葉をかけて心が行っちゃうと
もう演奏ができなくなって終わっちゃうんです
自分のパートは楽器は一回も弾くことできなくて
オーケストラ終わりとなっちゃうんですね
はい だからそういうふうにしてください
それはまあ それは正しいやり方なんですね
いろんなものを感じます
あの頭でもうチェックする余裕がないほど
骨組みを感じる人はいるし
細胞の伸び縮みを感じる人がいるし
いろいろ だから瞑想でどんどんすべてまとめて単純な言葉で実況できるのかっていうところは
次は進む方法なんです
そうなったら 初めからもう上げる
運ぶ 下ろすという単純な言葉にしているんです
だから途中で問題が起こることは
一応こちらは期待しているんです
こちらっていうのはブッダは
だから単純な言葉で瞑想は推薦しているんです
時々人々は自我を張って明確にかかとが上がる
土踏まずが上がる 指が上がる
地面から離れたそれから伸ばすとかね
あんなのね 自我張ってるだけ
ただ スマナサーラより私は明確にやっているんだよ
やってください 当たりませんよ
結局は自我ばっかりで
だからといって それに私には文句を言えませんよ
やりたければ構いませんだけど
もう感じるものをすべて実況しようと思っちゃうと
これはありえないんです
ですから このオーケストラのリズムを壊さないで持っていってください
そこら辺 今のうち気をつけてください
またまた次のステージも説明したかったんだけど
あんた最初から頭の中でもフォーマット入れちゃったんだからね
まあ一応そういうところで頑張ってみてください
次また成長したら説明してください
大変ありがとうございました
まだ若干時間ございます
あ はい えーと 涅槃はなんで無常じゃないんでしょうか？それとあの聖者の出世間心というのがあるんですが
ん？ 出世間心ですね 六ったら六識った
で その心情で見ますと
まああの 欲界の信条と違って
いろいろ善信条があるとか
禅定の信条があるとかあるんですけども
六根六塵であっても無常で生滅しているのに
無常で生滅している信条が
心が無常でない涅槃をどのように認識するのでしょう
その点を２点をお願いします
それは人がやるしかないでしょ
これ言葉でお釈迦様もそれは説明できないと言っているでしょうに
なんで私説明しなくちゃなんですかね
瞑想してみてください
ちゃんと集中力があって
すべての現象は無常であるとわかった人は
心がすぐ涅槃を体験します
だからやりたくない だから言葉で教えてくれって話でしょ
結局はね それはちょっと難しいんですよ
誰もやってないしね という説明は
それをあなたのすべて無常なのに
なんで涅槃は無常でないという質問じゃ
なんとか屁理屈それはもちろんいいんだけどね
それ自体はね  なんで涅槃は無常ではないかと
涅槃に対して常無常っていう形容詞は入らないんですよ
だから空間の高さを教えてくださいと言える？水の長さを教えてくださいと言える
水はだいたいこれは 2メートルぐらい長い水
これは 1 キロぐらい長い水とか
だから言葉の使い方が間違っているでしょう
だから  宇宙の空間の長さを教えてくださいなどなどなんですね
では 空間の例えば深さを言ってくださいと
ありえないんです この部屋があるならば
部屋には高さ横あるんだけど
空間ではないですね そんなのは
例えば私たちは部屋を作る
そこで空間が現れるでしょう
我々は壁に部屋と言わないで
空間の部屋と言うんですね
でも 空間が部屋になったのは壁のおかげなんですね
だから壁が原因で空間が部屋になったんです
そこで誰が無常ですか？壁ですか？空間ですか
なんていうのは瞑想しないで頭で理解したいという必死でしょ
では 答えてみてください
部屋を作ったんです それで空間が部屋になったんです
それでどちらが無常ですか？答えがなかったら私もそこで説明してしまいます
うん 部屋を作った時点で
そのその部屋の中での無常が生まれたということですか？ 見事に間違ってます
作った時点は問題ないんです
壁を作ったら そこをずっと壁が無常です
壁が無常です そちらに空間があったんです
人は因果法則によって壁が作ったんだから部屋になったんです
だから壁が壊れたら部屋がないんです
だから部屋は無常という意味じゃないんです
壁が無常です 部屋がないというのは空間がないということでしょ
そこで私はこちらで部屋を作って
その空間にいる 部屋がなくなったら私は死んじゃうんじゃなくて
無制限の空間にあるんです
そちらに無常って壁が作らないならば問題ないんです
問題は壁が作れなかった
仕切り作りたかった人にあるでしょうに
仕切りを作って有限的な空間にいたんです
それで仕切りが無常だからわからなくなっただけ
空間のこと 涅槃というのは因果法則によって現象が現れるだけ
それは現象をなくしてくださいと
それは涅槃という それが説明です
言葉の はい 以上です  ありがとうございます
うん もう一方ぐらい あ
はい  ウェーサーカ祭りの時の念処経の実践バージョンなんですが
えーと 眼は盲んでいます
貪欲という品より 瞋恚という品より
愚痴という品よりというところなんですが
愚痴という言葉はあまり聞かないので
普通無知というんですが
同じ考えですか？ん？無知という言葉があるんですが
え？うんうん どんな単語でもいいでしょうに
別に  次なんですが 仙人のビクタチ
仙人のビクタチにという仙人のビクタチは
仏教徒 仏教徒になってなったんですか
その後にこの念処経が説かれた
あと この念処経を説かれた時間というのはどれぐらいの長さの間説かれたんですか？ いや
全然わからないのに聞いてるのかよ
仙人のお坊さんのところにお釈迦様が行かれて
えっと あの 要するにガヤでカッサパ三兄弟を教化した時に
ガヤシータって山に登って
そこで元々火を信仰してた人たちに
その火の譬で説法したんですよね
だから逆にその譬が心に入って
サーッと悟りに達したということだと思います
説法はどれぐらい時間が経ったかってことは
経典では多分記録は全くないと思います
はい  あと一つです すみません
この実践 実践編なんですが
これを心を清らかにしようと真剣に読み上げることで心が変わるという考えでいいです
もう一度言ってみて なんか理解できない
心を込めて真剣に読み上げることで
その経典を自分の心も変わるというふうに理解していいのか
あ あ  その気があればね
真剣に やっぱり自分の心を変えることを期待して念じるという気持ちがあれば
変わる可能性はあります
だから私には約束できません
だってこれ煩悩のセットアップの問題だから
だからどんな程度で煩悩が設定しているかはわからないんだけど
とにかくものは試しっていうことで
いろんな方法はやってみます
だからこれ念じれば心は必ず変わるっていうね
だから変わるよねっていう気持ちでやった方がいいんです
儀式でやったっても何の意味もないんです
やっぱり心変わるというふうに思ってやった方がいいんです
例えばある人に私は言ったでしょ
慈悲の瞑想場合でも なんかマンネリになっちゃってうまくいかないんだと
だったらこうしましょうと
私の嫌いな人々も幸せでありますようにと念じて
そういう人間になりたいと
最後にちょっと一言葉入れてよと
それは念じなくてもいいんです
私を嫌っている生命も幸せでありますようにと思える人間になりたいなと
そう あれを入れることで心が変わっていくんです
だからといって テキストに我々はそれを書けません
それはその個人の方の問題なんです
だから思考っていうのは
早いんだから この二重三重で働く場合もあるでしょうに
生きとし生ける嫌いな人々も幸せありますね
あの田中野郎がねとかね
同時に思うこともあり得るんです
あいつはあんな態度がなければいいのにとかね
だからそれで慈悲になってないでしょうね
その瞬間で思える人間になりたいと
言った途端 田中の問題が消えちゃうんです
そういう風にまあ一応念じてみた方がいいとは思いますね
で 変わるっていうことは相当あり得るんです
瞑想したってもある程度で言葉念じることでしょう
どんな瞑想？言葉は入らない瞑想はないんです
あの曹洞宗のシカンタサ以外は
だから言葉を使わないシカンタサみたいな瞑想ってかえって危ないんです
なぜならば 何するのかと
人間の心はもう期待できんでしょ
かえって修行するの若者でしょ？すごい元気な若者たちがもう曹洞宗の本山に行ってね
二十歳そこそこの連中が
そいつらただで座っておく
頭の中何やってるか分かったもんじゃないんです
だから何かで制御するようになった方がいいとは思います
ですから 瞑想はだいたい何かしら
何かしら言葉使ってますね
何かしら言葉で制御しているんです
ヒンドゥー教でオームとか唱えること
オームナマシュヴァイとかね
オームバドラカーリーとかいろいろありますよ
呪文がね で あれで余計なこと
バドラカーリーナマクといって
バドラカーリーという鬼神の王様のことだけ思っている
念じる そこで制御ということになるんですね
はい まあそういうことで
変わる可能性はあるということ
答えです  はい それではちょうど時間になりましたので
質疑応答の時間 これで終了したいと思います
はい で 今日の説法会はね
かなりうまく進みました
私も事故を起こしちゃって
適当な時間で講演は終わることになりましたので
毎回事故を起こしてください
頼まないでください これ大変
それは困ります で 与那沢イスル様のお布施によって今日の説法会をうまく行くことができました
与那沢イスル様に ボランティアの方々に
今日説法をずっと聞いて理解した方々に
理解しなかった方々に
それでは理解したかったんだけどできなかった方々
皆様に幸福がありますように
三宝の御加護がありますように
常に真理に守られますようにと導かれますように
解脱に涅槃に達することができますように
誓願いたします はい  3回
サーッド サーッド サーッド
では 最後の誓願を読み上げます
ドゥッカム パンタ チェー ニン ドゥッカ―
ダヤッ パンタ チェー ニン ダヤ―
ソーカン パンタ チェー ニン ソーカ―
ホントゥ サンレー ピパーニノー
もう一回やります ドゥッカム パンタ チェー ニン ドゥッカ―
ダヤッ パンタ チェー ニン ダヤ―
ソーカン パンタ チェー ニン ソーカ―
ホントゥ サンレー ピパーニノー
苦しみ者の苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命が幸福ごとくありますように
ありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました
皆さんも今日はご来場いただきまして
どうもありがとうございます
えーと これにて本日の諸仏教立正講演会終了いたします
カンティー パラマン タポーティティンカー
ニッバーナム パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ